[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum i hope you're uh
enjoying your week ryan it's always a
pleasure to see you my friend hello good
to see you too sometimes i feel like my
energy is down but then
you know you don't want to be all high
strung on these things when people are
listening on the road and it's easy
going it's easy to listen to hey how are
you i don't want to hear that no you
want a comfort hanging you want it
comforting all announcers should talk
like this ryan should be gentle inside
of you gently inside of you
uh i appreciate all the uh the fan mail
i appreciate all the well wishes
um you guys are great all my patrons i
love you you know that if you want to
support the podcast in more than one way
go to patreon.com inside of you i'll
write a little message to you it's
awesome uh there's lots of perks some
people get boxes from me every couple
months and there's just tons of stuff
check it out patreon.com inside of you
uh and also we just we're gonna get
right into the interview but uh
uh if you wanna follow us if you're
listening for neil mcdonough i'd love
for you to follow the podcast on the
social and subscribe means a lot spread
the word uh at inside of you podcast on
the instagram and facebook at
insideyoupod on the twitter
and that's how that is and then you can
subscribe on youtube you can watch the
whole video or you could listen in your
car like some of you are doing right now
raj i know you're there i know you're
listening
just a random name i mean he's a patron
so i thought i'd give him a shout out
you know what i mean i hope he doesn't
crash when he hears that yeah so what
the heck no he'd probably just be upset
about it uh and if you want to shop at
the inside of you online store go there
and there's there's tons of stuff lex
luthor autograph pictures there's you
can get small the lunch boxes uh inside
of you tumblers t-shirts much more also
my band sunspin i'm wearing the sunspin
shirt you can go to sunspin.com
get shirts book zooms with me
uh lots of other stuff and uh
yeah that's that's that
and uh great guest did you enjoy this
one yeah it was a fun one i did this guy
has been in everything like
desperate housewives band of brothers
minority report flags of our father uh
walking tall
just
i mean everything he's been in
everything and he's always so committed
and what a great story and how open he
was
uh i'm excited about this one i think
this one's uh
i think people are gonna like this one i
hope you like it i'm sure you'll tell me
if you don't he's also a friend of mine
i play ice hockey with him
he he and his wife have a wonderful
relationship i love watching them
together they're the perfect example of
the rare example when a couple just
works
they work so well together and i love
the love that they share
and uh it gives me hope let's get inside
of neil mcdonough
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience all right so look uh we know
each other we we go to these hockey
tournaments it's been many years but i
always
i always just loved you and revere your
wife and
i just
you have this energy together where you
see a couple together and you're like oh
that couple you know that couple's gonna
make it a lot of couples you look at and
you don't see that but with you guys
with each other 21 years later that's
that's kind of the key to it it's you
know
you know we're sitting here last night
you know having dinner we're back here
in canada now we're quarantining for a
while
and you know a song comes on the radio
and the kids are just hanging we're all
having dinner and i just grabbed her
vein and started dancing in front of all
the kids and dipped her in corrupt her
and kissed her and that's what you do
you got to show your kids love too and
affection because that's you know that's
what that's what makes everyone happy
neil this podcast isn't about me but i
never saw that once
i never saw my father grab my mother and
kiss her and i mean maybe i saw him kiss
her once or but like yeah it was very
rare to see them
it was a different different time it was
uh
you know my mom and dad you know kiss
each other but i never saw them really
groping but you know they uh
yeah they were they were you know
affectionate enough in that time and age
but
you know now it's a different time and
it's okay to show your feelings and your
emotions towards people and and
you know i think i think that's that's
that's if there's anything good that's
come out of all this as of latest you
know find the people that you love and
love the snot out don't don't stop
loving and and enjoy them because you
don't know
what's up next you don't know what's
going on tomorrow you know and you can't
worry about what happened yesterday all
you can worry about is what's happening
in this moment right now and just find
the love you know and michael you've
always been that way you've always been
about okay it would be in the locker
room it's gonna be you know tense or
boring or something you'd come in and
start cracking jokes and make everyone
you know you know light and happy and
and you know you're amazing at that you
are the love infuser in every room that
i go to which is great well i think it
comes from insecurity i come into a room
and i just feel like i i have to say
something i have to do something if they
laugh they like me
[Music]
you know everyone's you know everyone's
serious in life life has been is has
gotten very serious on so many levels
yeah you know but eurozone you come in
and just you shake it up and it's it's
it's you know this is my by the way my
first podcast
this is the very first podcast you're
doing the very first one very first one
i'm honored that i'm on your show mike i
am honored to and i and i give credit a
lot to the wife the wifey river because
river made that happen didn't she
totally absolutely you know if it
weren't you i i i you know being a
pretty private guy why is it why is it
you don't do podcasts have you not been
asked i'm sure you've been asked yeah i
just i've just never i like
i love acting and i love the mystique of
neil mcdonough as this actor and that no
one really knows that much about him but
in real life from this really goofy
family guy
you know and i kind of
i like my private life with with
riveting the kids you know and as much
as i put myself out there you know i
coach all the kids in their sports or
you know i'm there for all the meetings
or different whatever it takes to make
the kids you know succeed whenever they
can succeed in or be happier you know
i'm always i'm all in but acting to me
is my job and i generally don't talk
about it too much
all right well well by the way we have
this new segment called um
how you doing it's kind of a mental
health check-in it's just how you doing
and and it's just like right now i know
you're quarantining in in canada and
you've got the family you got five of
you and well six of you counting revere
seven of you counting your name
you're the brady bunch but i mean how
are you doing are you are i mean look
you're a happy go lucky guy but uh
you know how are you feeling
how you doing almost been that guy you
know i have a great relationship with
god and that's kind of paramount to me
and it's god first me second or family
first me second
you know those kind of the mantras that
i always kind of live by
so you know through all this you know
through this pandemic as horrible and
horrific as as it has been for so many
people you know you know just you know
tragic on you know personal ways and
economic ways there's so many ways that
that's been so hard and it's been hard
on us too but you know overall
it has given me
you know a phenomenal gift that i got to
spend an exorbitant amount of time with
my wife and my five kids you know and
you know we just did a film this last
year uh called boone that verbanite
produced together uh and we did in
spokane which was which was awesome
uh and you know the whole family was
with us the whole time so literally i
was sitting we're sitting here having
dinner last night and sitting around the
table and i said to her i said you know
we haven't we've been with the kids
24 7 for a year
and we love each other more today than
we did even yesterday and it's it's been
such a blessing to get to hang out with
you know with them and get to know them
because usually we're at work where
you're traveling or this or they're at
sports or their ballet or something you
know it's been great that on on one
level that we got to spend so much time
with each other and learn from each
other and try to make each other better
but don't you don't i mean come on
you're human you got to have bad days
you got to have you lose your stuff
every once in a while i know absolutely
you're you know we're dads or humans
we're husbands but but you know you're
always trying to be you know you know i
i'm blessed that i'm not that
intelligent you know that i can just
keep my nose down and keep pressing with
the same kind of message in my head of
trying to find goodness and try to be
the best that i can be in everything
that i do wow you know so it's it's kind
of always a driving force to me how can
i eat better well what can i do to to
work out better what can i do to make
god happy what can i do to make proven
to kids happier so
like five years ago
you know you know as a young as a good
irish guy you know i love drinking you
know it was it was part of my everyday
thing and it was always there and
accessible especially in hollywood it's
like hey neil have a drink have another
drink have another drink and five years
ago i just cut it out i said okay i'm
done i can't do this anymore and for
five years i've been sober and it's been
you know you know
the greatest decision second greatest
decision i ever made in my life other
than obviously asking river to marry me
were you were you drinking a lot though
for someone to see yeah
i was a hollywood guy you're always
drinking it's always part and i'm irish
so you know
it definitely became a problem for me
and it was a problem that i didn't want
my kids to see and i didn't want
look being being trying to be the best
dad you can be
that doesn't fit in trying to be the
best husband you can be it doesn't fit
and trying to be great at work
you know the last five years have worked
for me have been you know really just
phenomenal from just being
you know the bad guy in everything to
you know the good guy now i'm off doing
ryan murphy just called me this week to
to play eisenhower in american horror
story wow
wow i could totally see that
i could totally see that's fantastic
yeah so you know
the good lord works in strange ways here
we are you know are
moving back to california don't know
where don't know what we're going to do
and then we get this that you know i'm
shooting the show now this fall you know
at fox
you know it's it's a great way to come
back into los angeles uh and i you know
i couldn't be happier or more blessed
that that this gift was given to me from
above and from ryan murphy that's
amazing so uh when i meet ryan he's
gonna be a big hug going his way because
that's that's such a great gift to play
someone that i have always looked up to
as you know
you know a centrist when it comes to
politics as was eisenhower
you know the things that that guy did
you know everyone you know he was he
almost ran out of the democratic ticket
republican you know he finally rented
public
ticket but now he was this amazing guy
who cared so much about humanity and
uh learning so much about him now in the
last couple days doing more research i'm
just i'm i'm
you know
gobsmacked at how fortunate i am
that is freaking awesome you know you
talk about religion and you're a devout
catholic and you've been i mean was this
something that was instilled on you by
your parents
and or from from a young age that you
just kept with you and it got stronger
and stronger was that a kind of thing or
did you find it at an age or how did
that happen
no it was it was
you know my parents were you know
growing up in boston i lived right
across the street from the church at
saint peter's so
um
you know i was always at the church or
you know playing stickball in front of
the church or you know you know when we
finally moved to cape cod i spent a lot
of time you know going to mass every
sunday with you know my mom and we had a
hotel so my mom would go to the early
mass uh my dad would go to the evening
mass your parents own their motel owners
yeah small motel mom and pop motel 40
room hotel in cape cod great way to grow
up had a lake had a coffee shop
you know by the time i was five i was
washing dishes in the restaurant and
showing rooms and you know you know and
by the time i was 20 i was you know
running uh we bought a second motel uh
and
uh it was just a great way to grow up
and learn business it was a really
fantastic place right but
you know so i would go to church with my
dad
you know on sundays at five o'clock and
you know it was it was always just a
bonding time with me and my dad and i
always loved that time and you know we
would do the baskets and do the
collections and then we'll go to john's
loft restaurant which is in hyannis the
whole family would meet after
you know my brothers and my sister uh
you know four older brothers and older
sisters they all went to parochial
school i was the only one who didn't
so you know i'm the only one who's
really still practicing catholicism
which was it was interesting so it was
more of an organic uh
you know relationship that i that i had
and then when i was in high school uh i
did this
uh thing called echo and i really became
close to god in my relationship and
tried to just aspire to be
better instead of being you know
you know
i just try to be the best at everything
i could do right i became very
competitive with just myself not with
anybody else and
it was a relationship with god always
just say be the best you can be just try
harder well that's got to be tough
that's got to be tough because in this
in hollywood to be someone who's
religious now obviously we you've talked
about this ad nauseam and people know
about it but like you've gotten like
released or couldn't do roles or refuse
to do roles based on like you won't do a
kissing scene
right but some of them for some unless
you know the great yeah i won't do
kissing scenes i've never wanted to do
it and you know i got crucified about 10
years ago where they thought i was this
religious zealot that i wouldn't do sex
scenes it was really because i love my
wife more than i love my craft and
people couldn't understand i can't they
couldn't grasp that so i had to become
the best bad guy
because i had to provide for my five
kids and a beautiful wife and so
you know
that's what i had to keep doing and then
finally a couple years ago when i
started to executive produce things i
did this movie called greater which is
this faith-based football film
a phenomenal movie and and
you know that started me on the trend of
doing these
good guys with this great past and
grappling with their faith and now this
is this film that we just finished
called boon
uh is that he's a hitman who has to find
his placement with god and it's
you know it's great that i that review
vehicles for me that i get to write and
and be in that i don't have to just do
uh you know
movies that are out there that i have to
go fight for i can build my own movies
and and and craft them that way and so
so for me to also have that
ability to to make movies that talk
about god and talk about how we are
flawed how we all make mistakes and how
it's how you
you know get up after you make a mistake
not not wallowing in your mistake yeah a
better person and and i like making
movies like that tv shows like that and
you know that's
if i never make a movie for anyone else
again for the rest of my life i'm okay
with it yeah as long as i'm making
movies that that's cool
i mean you know that you talk about that
and you do you think
it was scoundrels right that was the big
thing that scoundrels you wouldn't do a
sex scene or something and then they
released you and so you saying after
that it was it was a very difficult time
in your life for work i mean were you or
were you only getting out
talk about drinking then you know there
was two years of me not getting a job
and losing my
you know big house in hancock park and
cars and everything and begging from
this and you know i was never a guy who
would ask to borrow money from anyone
i'd rather just figure out myself so i
lost basically everything
uh and then you know i've told the story
before that you know
you know and me being a great you know
go to church every day you're always
praying trying to figure out what's
going on
in one day in my house you know before
we had to sell it before i got
foreclosed on to start with
um
you know i remember saying to god why
have you forgotten about me what have i
done that i deserve this and as soon as
i came out of my mouth michael i fell to
the ground and started sobbing
uh and two minutes later i got a phone
call from graeme yost who wrote band of
brothers in boom town goes hey you want
to be the villain on a couple episodes
of justified
yes i do
uh it was kind of the greatest thing
that ever happened to me in so many ways
because
i i fell in love with acting again
because i had something to prove i had
to prove to everyone that you know that
i am a great actor and and that you know
a person that you want to have on your
set and after the very first take of the
first scene uh graham come up to me goes
you want to be the villain for the whole
year don't jump nice yeah i do and i was
and
because of that you know awards came and
attention came and all of a sudden
everyone started forgetting about
uh the other stuff and you know it's
been you know the last 10 years of work
has been you know
coming up here in vancouver with all the
shows
you know i owe so much to greg
berlantiber for bringing me up for for
you know
flash and legends and yellowstone came
up with that in suits and you know all
these other shows and movies it's just
been uh it's just been a phenomenal
phenomenal couple of years and
uh yeah
i could i couldn't be happier
inside of you is brought to you by
geico that's right geico
tell you what it's a name that everybody
knows ryan everybody knows ryan nobody
doesn't know geico yes that's true i uh
i i own my house you rent your house
we've talked about this millions of
times
but it's so geico makes life easier for
all of us let's just be honest you know
when i go to the grocery store i talk
about this i like a service to bring my
groceries i don't have time i've got a
lot going on man i'm a busy guy
so geico does the same thing with
insurance policies do you know what
they're called bundling that's correct
ryan i know things
bundling policies
um we have already have so much on our
plate guys i know you're busy just as i
am and uh geico makes it easy to bundle
your homeowners or renters insurance
along with your auto policy imagine you
could just pay them all at once and
you're gonna get a great price it's
geico easy just go to geico.com
get a quote and see how much you can
save it's geico easy visit geico.com
today that's geico.com
inside of you is brought to you by
chirpwheel guys listen to me i love you
i hope you're watching the video if not
you could just imagine but i brought
these wheels in these chirp wheels
look at this and you know i have back
problems
and these things are the most i've seen
wheels before there's there's other
wheels around this is the best thing
i've ever rolled on
this
releases tension and it's the most
comfortable it has this divot in the
middle and they come in three different
sizes because when you're rolling
you want the option so even when you
have the small one you could roll and
your back can be on the ground and then
you got the very
large wheel
and it's just flexibility man you keep
switching the the wheels and you get
more flexible i uh it reduces pain i
roll out little painful uh
inflammation sections of my back
um i've had a lot of surgeries i know
what the hell i'm talking about when it
comes to this so if you want to listen
to me about one thing
it's chirp wheel folks
it's freaking chirp wheel chirp is a
brand dedicated to helping the world
feel good so they could do more of the
stuff that they love in other words
chirp is all about feel good do more to
do this chirp creates simple innovative
and effective pain relief and prevention
solutions chirp started with a
revolutionary wheel for the back but
they're just getting started back pain
prevents millions of people from feeling
their best when they don't feel their
best they're limited at what they can do
and chirp
can help fix that with chirps patent
pending spinal canal and three different
pressure options to choose from chirp
will help your back feel better so you
can be back to doing what you love in no
time three different pressure sizes
gentle medium deep
spinal canal to comfort your spine as
our wheels give your back a unique
four-way stretch each wheel can hold up
to 500 pounds they can be nestled
together for easy travel to take with
you wherever you go so here's what you
do you got to take my word for this i
love the chirp wheel i use it all the
time probably three times a day for at
least 15 minutes and it makes my life so
much easier and i feel so much better
just visit
gochirp.com go geo
chirp c-h-i-r-p dot com go chirp.com and
enter promo code inside to get 10 off
site-wide inside of you is brought to
you by hello fresh
i like these guys they make life easier
and you know how i like things easy
with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered
right to your door it skips trips to the
grocery store and count on hellofresh to
make home cooking
easy fun and affordable and that's why
it's america's number one meal kit and
i'll tell you
i had it delivered to me i cannot go to
the grocery store and try to make a dish
and and so oh well i this is what i need
and go
you know you get the book out or some
recipe
they have it all for you everything is
measured out perfectly everything you
need to go into your meal it's easy
it's healthy i love this stuff
hellofresh fall is busy but hello fresh
recipes save time you'd otherwise spend
meal planning shopping and chopping so
you can get back to what matters hello
fresh's family friendly menu is a big
win for back to school season with easy
delicious recipes for drama-free dinners
hellofresh offers 50 menu and market
items to choose from every week 50 from
vegetarian meals and calorie smart
choices to extra special gourmet option
there's something for everyone to enjoy
with recipes designed and tested by
professional chefs and nutritional
experts to ensure deliciousness and
simplicity
i had this wonderful chicken meal with
vegetables and it was just
it was really damn good i gotta say that
and i prepared it myself and it only
took me like a short time to do it i
would have been frantic trying to make a
meal and at the end i go well you are a
chef look at you
look at you can cook you can make a meal
and it feels good it feels like you're
not just ordering it all the time and
spending an exorbitant amount of money
on ordering i mean
i just love it
you know what's great is hellofresh is
over 30 cheaper than shopping at the
grocery store there you go go to
hellofresh.com
iou14
and use the code
iou14 for up to 14 free meals including
free
shipping hellofresh.com
iou14 and use code iou14
for up to 14 free meals including free
shipping what are you waiting for i like
the word free hello fresh
i mean do you deep down
like playing the villain better or is it
kind of like you don't because you
you've played it so many times
you know i mean it's it's not that i i i
really like playing guys more like us
guys who are human and guys sort of
flawed guys are trying to do the right
thing and right those are the guys that
that that i've always gravitated towards
i've always loved you know you know john
wayne's movies you know i always loved
you know clint eastwood's movies i love
the simple messages of this guy's flawed
at the end of the day he's going to be
the puppy doyle he's going to get the
job done you know however he has to do
it he's going to get the job done
and i love those guys you know it's kind
of like you know my dad or my family
growing up you know we'd get the job
done and that's kind of the guys that i
like so i wanted to play villains yeah
they're fun they're absolutely fun you
know what it's like playing building one
of the greatest villains of all time and
you know to to have that
you know kind of fun you know you can
never make a bad choice as long as you
believe it you can go as long as you
want as small as you want as a villain
no one ever gives you notes good guys
get notes
that's for sure
for me
i could kill 50 guys in a scene and
after that you know we're laughing and
going back home and everything's gone
but if as a good guy
you know with you know hard on the
sleeve type of characters i've been
playing especially for the last few
years it's hard to slough those guys up
you have to go back to you know buck
content band of brothers or you know
wyatt kane and tin man those are the
good guys that i played that were really
hard for me to shake off because i had
to really dig deep into me and pull out
more of the real neil mcdonough to play
those characters instead of playing
demian dark which was a blast don't get
me wrong i had i had a phenomenal time
playing damien dark for all these years
um and i look forward to playing him
again but i do love playing you know the
good guys because they get to learn more
about me and appreciate what i have is
uh morgan little buck is that uh that
comes from little buck is bigger than me
now he's you know 15 and 6 foot one and
you know he's you know
just this great kid he
you know all the kids have done you know
really well and rivets just you know
just the most incredible mother
you know so they're doing really well in
school really well in sports um
you know morgan uh last year
uh as a freshman they gave away this
this award citizen of the year
uh in his high school and they gave it
to morgan and i was like well it's
because he got all a's and captain's
teams and asked ask the principal he
goes no it's what he does with the
developmentally disabled kids
it's like what you didn't know this i
didn't know and he goes yeah he walks
every morning he takes the kids who have
you know down syndrome or autism and
walks into the cafeteria for lunch and
how old
and when he was 14 at a time you know
when a freshman high school
uh grade eight up here uh so
you know i asked him about him because
yeah well you know people kind of
perceive me to be this kind of
good cool kid i guess so i said you know
i don't want to see these kids get
laughed at so i walk them into village
that just
makes me want to tear up right there i
just felt it like right when you said
that like and that
i got to tell you that's good parenting
i mean you know things like that it's
you know and we try to infuse you know
we talk about god a lot talk about your
relationship with with god in life and
how you can strive to be the best you
can be at you know whatever you do and
to try to always do the right thing when
a lot of people don't have
the bravery or the you know the hood
spotting up and to kind of do the right
thing and and you know you know that kid
is you know he does it and now that
permeates to all of our other kids you
know our kids are
you know they're all dynamite you know
in their own different ways and you know
rive and i are just so blessed to have
them as our kids and getting to know
them so well over the last year it's
been you know the blessing on the cage i
love it you just did a uh a june 6 that
the d-day zoom with 200 people from band
of brothers who was on that zoom with
you
anybody famous
well donnie wahlberg finally came on
which is great donnie was in uh kirk
acevedo was on there uh freddie joe our
technical advisor and a bunch of the
cast and
it was basically mostly just fans just
is kind of tuning in and again you know
i don't this is the first time i had
done any kind of zoom thing for better
brothers and
it was awesome you know
that matthew put this whole thing
together and to talk about the braver of
these guys you know everyone who was
part of better brothers learned so much
because we got to learn from from a
generation that didn't complain you know
you know here you are light infantry
supposed to be going into normandy for a
day or two with with a leg bag that is
probably going to get blown off your leg
that is of course if you survive the
landing
and then to be there for you know almost
two months you know without
you know having a scrounge for food on a
scratch for weapons having spanish with
bullets scratch for everything you know
these guys learned toughness at a young
age and
you know
it it it
permeated through us like crazy you know
i remember we were talking about the
other day
about four or five days into boot camp
it was almost like a mutiny because they
were just beating us up so bad which you
know i really enjoyed
uh really you enjoyed that
my dad was a sergeant in the army so i i
love pt i love you know that
i enjoy that stuff i really do
um
so did you see other guys cry did
anybody get right yeah just a lot of the
english guys couldn't you know because
the pro so pro american you know bad
brothers are fantastic a lot of the
english guys who just the sweetest
nicest guys are like what is what
what did we sign up for
uh and then tom hanks came in uh a
helicopter with his castaway beard and
hair
and gave us this speech as to why we owe
it to the men of easy company to work
our butts off to tell the truth because
they died for us and we're not for them
we wouldn't be speaking english right
now we wouldn't be the american that we
are right now we wouldn't be the great
country that we became we're not for
these men who gave their lives for us
michael after that everyone's just like
yes sir was he emotional was he
emotional during that speech yeah
because it meant the world to him yeah
it wasn't just because it was his show
and you know he was the producer and
writer and director and you know he he
tom hanks is different from from just
about everyone else i've ever met
because he did it because it was the
right thing you know he flew from all
the way from hawaii just for a 20 minute
speech and then flew right back
who does that you know you know it could
have been a video conference or
something way back then or something but
no tom hank said let's let's get on a
plane and fly over there and talk to the
boys and make sure they're on the right
track and after that you know we
we tore it up because we knew we ordered
to these guys who gave everything for
our freedom what was the worst day that
you could remember that you were just
physically and mentally done more so
than you've ever been there had to be
probably it was a winter's day i i would
assume yeah no it would the the hardest
you know for me always knowing that my
character is going to have a mental
breakdown
i got the greatest acting lesson here i
went to syracuse university and lambda
in london the greatest schools theater
all over the place pure method actor
crazy um and about two months into
dating river
because we met on the first day i got
into town uh she says look
you you you're not my sergeant you're
gonna
like work you you punch your card clock
and when you're done work your work and
stays at work and you live your life
after
method actor you know i live my
character 24 7 this is what i'm supposed
to do those are the two loneliest days
i've ever had and i finally went back to
urban i was like you know i think you
got to point that i may need to live my
life a little more instead just worrying
about the character and after that you
know since then my you know i
had helped so much with acting i i
couldn't even explain to you that you
have to open up to life to really become
a great vessel for whoever is giving you
the dialogue so you're able to turn off
like you're able to turn off now you're
not i can turn up between takes i i
figured out a way to really
uh to do that because you know that it
was a gift that gave me and
you know when i'm working i'm working
but when i'm when i'm not i can you know
challenge and such but you know the
worst thing knowing knowing that my
character is going to break down was
when i had to do my final you know near
the end when butt company started to
break
you know that that was
by far the hardest thing that i've
probably ever had to do
as an actor after spending so much time
with these guys
knowing what buck went through uh and to
see his friends just blown up in front
of him
um
you know that moment where i came out of
the foxhole and i dropped my helmet was
just
it was you know pent up emotion from
several months of knowing this moment
was coming and
what came out of me was was
you know unscripted and just raw and i
just you know i like to call it puking
on the canvas and i love just puking my
soul on a canvas and that was that was
one of my best pukes
you know i just i just let it all out
there because you know
i i you know i owed it to to buck and
his family and to everyone to make sure
that i did it right and i i think we did
and it was it was such a blessing do you
like direction do you like when a when a
director comes up to you and and and
tells you first of all i hate direction
on the first take let me do a first take
before you give me any notes here let's
let's let me get into this a little bit
but is it something that you
you you welcome it you enjoy it you uh
or is it something that just you know
always rubs you the wrong way usually
and you're like [ __ ] here we go again
well
being being an athlete that i was you
know
playing so many years in sports right
that
i treat the first take like it's game
day
so
i'd get uber prepared for things
you know i know my dialogue backwards
and forwards and upside down and
everything you know jimmy stewart when
you know once i read this one quote and
goes what's the key to hacking it's just
memorizing your lines over and over and
over and over and over again and then
just saying that
and it's just something true to that so
for me my first take is always
my best take
so
i'm always really prepared and i come
with such
choices then you know i'll talk to the
director beforehand you know to kind of
say okay what are you feeling for this
and you know what what's your take on
this and i'll take their information his
or her direction and then and then
have that in the back of my head and
work with it
um
so
i don't generally get a lot of direction
because i'm so prepared you know on tv
you don't have a lot of time for
direction anyway because get your lines
out let's move on we got a 12 page day
to go
so you know you better be prepared when
it comes to feature films you know
directors have a little bit more time it
can kind of tweak and get little nuances
and such so i do like when you know good
directors have good ideas
i don't particularly like when bad
directors have bad ideas and you know
i'll just nod politely and say thank you
and
um try and try to make them try to make
them happy too you know i always want to
make everybody happy as a team player
right but you know i definitely prefer
good direction i mean have you ever had
it where you have this direction and
you're so set on what you want to do and
it's like a 180 and this guy's asking
you to do things that you're like uh and
it's frustrating and you like how do you
deal with that have you dealt with that
yeah in my earlier years when i'd come
in with this is what i'm going to do and
wouldn't take into consideration what
everyone else was doing you know then
that would be hard you know right out of
the game but i learned quick to this
isn't about me it's a team sport acting
to me is the greatest team sport
so for me it's it's being as malleable
as as possible like a big piece of clay
just memorizing my dialogue and taking
in what the director has so if you come
in so set as so this is your game plan
like ali ali would go into a fight and
you really wouldn't watch much tape and
see he'd feel the punches in the first
round or two and kind of get through it
you know and that's that's kind of from
acting for me i don't want to with such
a game plan that
you know if this is exactly what i'm
going to do and the director wants
something exactly different well then
then
that's not going to work right so it's
you know this is why i love producing
now because uh
you know you know look i've been doing
it long enough i've been doing 130
movies and tv shows but i don't know
what the town is now
i know this i see celebrating my 53rd
death scene in a movie
you've died 53 times three times good
ones too not like like fiddly want like
good solid death scenes and movies of tv
show so it's pretty awesome somebody
needs to do a compilation of that and
show all your death scenes in in in
order
oh that would be
good isn't that wouldn't that be great
that'd be really good yeah yeah that'd
be great what's your best death your
favorite death scene that you were in
um
being stabbed to death in the chest by
anthony hopkins in red 2 was just a
blast because well it was with anthony
hawkins
that was pretty great
um
death seems i mean there's just so many
good ones
um
well didn't you die in ravenous
oh died died in a rabblistic ravenous
yeah i got eaten in ravenous that was
that was great fun
um they hung me upside down to kill me
and drive me out like a like like a
lamb skewer and just fillet me i guess
that was the best i mean you were nuts
in that movie you and and
carlisle
that you know we're shooting in the
czech republic in slovakia and i made
him take
the beds out of my hotel room so i sleep
on the floor like a soldier and run
obscene amounts of miles and run up
water mains you know including i'm kind
of a little claustrophobic so i figured
my character had to overcome his fears
of this and i was nuts you know you know
ice cold baths every day just to prove
how tough i was and bazillion push-ups
and weights and everything you know
it was now i do the same thing but but
you know different you know it's uh
you know you know i've grown as a human
being and i think
you know even after doing all this
acting for so many years i feel like i'm
just scratching at it now i'm really
starting to understand oh that's the new
onset that i was looking for years ago
that i wasn't smart enough or confident
enough to be able to do it and now
after doing it with so many people and
for so many people
you know it's it's it's a lot easier for
me now to be able to to really act well
and again you know a lot of it because i
have so much to draw from when when you
have a wife like raven five kids and a
great life there's tons of things that
you can draw from good and bad so
you know by having a big wholesome life
it certainly helps with my acting for
certain you do you do what i do you you
say you said it a couple times where
you're not that smart which is is
[ __ ] i i say that and my listener is
always like stop saying you're not smart
stop doing that to yourself it stems
from childhood and not thinking it was
smart enough and people tell me i'm not
smart enough so i say it uh it's not
that i think i'm an idiot i just think
everybody's different different caliber
of smart you know street smart whatever
uh obviously you're smart you're an
intelligent guy i mean you couldn't be
doing the things you're doing
right i you know i'm a good hunch person
i go with my my gut in state is always
really good yeah you know it you know
you can go to the great universities in
the world and so on so it doesn't sound
like smart you know rebay never went to
college and she's by far the smartest
certainly
the most streetwise savvy person that i
know and she can ask people things that
i wouldn't even have the balls to even
think about asking and she gets it done
and
you know everyone says you've had such a
great career you know like yeah i've had
such a great career because my partner
is you know so phenomenal and she keeps
me cranking she's like you know what'd
you do today
how how have you moved the needle
forward you know so you know always
having that
you know in my corner
is is immeasurable of the importance to
that
inside of you is brought to you by keeps
i'll tell you i have friends that are
going bald
i have
relatives that are going bald
and if you don't have to go bald
why should you
right
so i told my friends about this product
and they're using it and they're seeing
results
keeps you know two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35
more than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness and
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps
offers both
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't have to leave your home
it's low cost treatments start at just
ten dollars per month and keeps offers
generic versions discreet packaging and
proven results keeps has more five star
reviews than any of its competitors
prevention is key folks treatments can
take four to six months to see results
so act fast if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash inside of you to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's right that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash inside of you to get your
first month
free
k e e p s dot com slash inside of you
inside of you is brought to you by
better help
better help online therapy i can't tell
you how much this works it's obvious
they're still in my sponsor
i love them ryan uses them it if you do
and like if you're feeling depressed or
you're struggling with uh uncertainty or
having difficulty sleeping
better help offers experienced
therapists who can listen
and help um ryan you're still going
still going still going still uh
enjoying it well enjoying but yeah well
you know what it is there's something
enjoyable about it still getting use
good use out of it and feeling better
once it is done
i think when you get done with your
conversation with your therapist it's
cathartic it is it's sort of like
huh i could do this yeah right that's
how i feel that's what i mean to say yes
yes
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional you can start communicating
in under 48 hours uh there's a broad
range of expertise available which may
not be locally available in many areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide you just log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy it is kind of
uncomfortable when you're just sitting
there and someone else walks and you're
going i wonder what he's here for
what's your damage uh what's going on
with you man
and that's just the thing it does
there's nothing wrong with any of us
we just all have our issues we all have
things problems we all have things that
are cluttered up inside of us and it's
just good to get it out so there's all
levels that you don't have to
be
clinically depressed you don't have to
you know you could have issues and talk
through them with one of these
therapists uh better help is committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matches so they make it easy and free to
change counselors if needed we've talked
about this if you don't like your
counselor many don't
so you just pick another one they'll get
you another one and you find the right
fit it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available it's so much
cheaper than offline i i could talk
about that for a while in fact so many
people have been using better health
that they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
inside of you is sponsored by better
help online therapy and our listeners
get 10 off their first month of online
therapy at betterhelp.com
slash inside that's better h e l p
dot com slash inside betterhelp.com
inside get matched with a better health
therapist
and get started
you know you always hear about people
constantly working like i'm like why
does that guy go from movie to movie i
mean he can't be alone with himself or
that woman that actress can't
it amazes me how you can go from one job
to the next job
you really when you hear about these
actors who just
love
acting
are you do you really truly just love it
you want to act every day if you could
not every day for certain you know
bowling i do i don't
you know playing villains on tv for the
last six years you're working two days a
week and you know the cushy hours you
know the doctor's hours you know so i
get to have a life you know if you're
the you know i've been the lead guy on
tv shows before
and that's
it's brutal it's so people understand
how hard it is you know to do
you know 14 hours a day plus traveling
there and back you know before you know
your hair and makeup you know you're 16
17 hours a day for nine months of the
year and you get burnt and you don't
really get to act
or enjoy it so much
you know now with the 10 episode types
of orders it's so much more refreshing
and the writing gets better and the
shows are better
um i think so you know right now we're
in that you know in a perfect time for
for acting that there's tons of stuff
out there uh you can and if you you know
yeah i'm blessed because i get work
asked to work
you know a ton but i also love i love
being in front of a camera you know it's
it's my favorite team sport you know
getting in front of that camera and
creating something really terrific and
you know it's
you know for me i it's the only job i've
ever really had it's the only job i
could ever i love how my thing in the
bun says morgan mcdonough i just noticed
i just noticed that too yeah yeah
um so
um
yeah
long may i keep working because it's
it's something i'm
you know i can't pound a nail you know
i'm not good at a lot of things but my
catchphrase is but man i can act and
you know you know it's and it works you
know people keep hiring me because i'm
really good at what i do and i'm good on
a set and and it's you know i love doing
what i do um it helps comparison to how
much i love my wife and kids yeah but
that shows on the set you know i would
enjoy acting more if it just didn't take
as long
like these like tv shows there's like
all of a sudden you're four hours on one
scene
and when i was younger i would do it i
would play around but now you get to be
in your 40s you're almost 50 and you're
like
these it's it's a lot of work of doing
the same redundancies well you know i
mean you were you're on one of the
biggest hit shows of all time playing
one of the greatest villains of all time
what was that like
i mean it was i wasn't the lead so even
though i had to shave my head and work
you know three or four days a week and
there were long hours but i wasn't
working five six days a week 14 hours
like you were talking about like tom was
tom had
that that was that was a handful that
was not easy but you know when you talk
about committing um
playing that villain it was it did weigh
on me though it did weigh on me because
i felt like i was always just intense i
was trying i would try when the camera
stopped i would make jokes and laugh and
fart but like i had to because it was
just so intense especially some seasons
where i had to flip out but look i i i
think for me i did acting because
you know i was accepted i think that
people as a young you know when i was in
high school
no one knew who i was no one cared who i
was and then i did a play and all of a
sudden people like oh you're pretty good
at that
and then i was like oh then hell i guess
i should just do that and i told the
story but like it's it's true and then i
just started doing it because oh you're
good at it and people like when you do
that but i never thought for a second to
you how much i enjoyed it and i think i
enjoyed it for a time
and i think i will again
but you know i'm definitely not so eager
like i used to be like i got to work i
got to do this i think
and i'm very lucky in a lot of ways and
i'm very grateful but i'm also
you know i i'm always curious to see you
know
how much actors really love acting and
that's just their their passion or they
do it because it's a paycheck or
so i don't know it gets a little
convoluted yeah it it you know
you gotta say if you do for a paycheck
you do it for the wrong reasons you have
you have to do i tell my kids or
everybody tells kids you know don't play
a sport because you think that's going
to be your key to getting a scholarship
for for college play sport because you
love playing sport and then be the best
that you can be
it's kind of simple but you got to
practice you got to put in the time you
got to put in the effort you got to work
hard towards something if you want to be
great at something you know so for me i
love acting i literally love
being in front of a camera and creating
something different you know
um
so you're the play that you were in high
school do you remember
of course i do it's the play that
everybody does see if you could name it
guys and dolls close grease
i played this guy i played this guy
vince fontaine he was just the wacky dj
he came and goes hey i'm the main brain
vince fontaine spinning the stacks of
wax here at the house of wax waxx
cruising time 10 26
sharp shooters and i did this
and i remember i still remember it oh
yeah and for the first time in my life i
remember i was terrified i mean terrific
to the point where i they had this
little waxx box dj box on the second
floor of the stage and
the director said michael
we need to see you because i was hiding
behind it so you could just hear me we
need to see your face we need to see
your face keep moving keep moving i was
so scared to be seen and it wasn't until
that play ended and i walked out
and i wasn't the lead role i wasn't a
big role
and the applause you hear a difference
in applause
and i was listening i was like wait a
minute they just applauded a lot loud
louder loudly for whatever for me and
they just went nuts and i it felt
i had a feeling that i never had i had
before where
hey you're good at something that was
the first time i thought
and that that's how i became an actress
really because
i think if they would have booed me off
the stage or i don't know if i was okay
or
i needed to be great in that moment to
then become an actor i had to be great i
think in that moment in order to keep
doing it and having the confidence to
keep doing it
it was when i was in high school
he was uh and i tell my kids
i uh
i couldn't find myself couldn't find out
who i was you know my brother uh
you know selected my courses for my
freshman year and he was my brother was
just this crazy smart guy
and my you know i was failing my
freshman year in high school and i
didn't make the hockey team and i didn't
make the baseball team i was like what
is going on with my life
and then i auditioned for
uh
snoopy and you're a good man charlie
brown
and i went to the audition my mom
practiced with me at home and i went to
audition and
i nailed it and
the director was like who are you i'm
like you only done tenant like where are
you from like
from from here from hyannis
well i've never seen you any place
before like i know i've been saying the
same thing yeah i didn't get i tried for
the first second third fourth fifth
sixth seventh and eighth grade plays and
i got nothing
and finally you know my freshman year i
get this and my opening night
i go to standing ovation
and after that
everything in my life changed
you know it was because of theater that
all of a sudden i started building up
that confidence again and before you
know it i was
you know
back on the sports teams class president
class clown all these things i remember
you know listening to an album by george
carlin said if you're going to amount to
anything in life
it starts with you becoming the class
clown in high school and i took that to
heart and you know i i became the class
clown you know who would have thought
that you know when i came to hollywood
to be a comedian i turned into the very
dramatic actor uh that i became which is
pretty interesting because i was always
the goofy clown guy
but if it weren't you know we're similar
we had that that rush at 14 years old of
oh this is a complete acceptance right
here this is a good feeling i want to
keep doing this and then after that it
was just
it was the only job i've ever really had
my whole life is entertaining people
yeah i think the stars have to align i
think they did
in a lot of ways it sounds for you i
mean and for me even i went when i went
to college
i was still terrified and and these look
for everybody listening
acting classes in the green rooms where
the actors hang out
they are the most intimidating effing
rooms
that you could be in they all are like
oh he sucks he's you know i'm better
than him they had this look on their
faces like they're just you know olivier
and i'm just in there going i don't know
hey guys trying to befriend everybody
making jokes like i did in the locker
room like you were talking about earlier
that's right and then i remember just
finally
you know in class i was i was i did
something
and an actor comes up to me goes hey i'm
directing this play and my actor just
fell off will you do it and i was
confronted like i i don't know if i even
would have become an actor really but he
he just says could you please do it and
i said
yes and it was prelude to a kiss and it
was this the role of her father and
again
scared to death but then i heard that
applause again and that
something rang in my brain that said
okay dude now this is obvious you have
to do this which which wasn't my father
i remember taking us out to denny's he
was a fancy guy we like denny's and i'm
like i want to be an actor i was like a
sophomore in college and he goes eat
your steak i'll never forget that just
eat your steak he didn't want to talk
about that it was like he works for
pharmaceutical plant he busted his ass
he's never missed a day of work he
worked hard he worked you know and then
you want to be an actor you're going to
college to become
an actor
and so
you know i didn't get that
immediate support i don't think they and
i had to prove to myself and prove to
them that i was good enough so
i think you're always doing that right
you're always trying to prove to
everybody that you're good
it's it's once in life you only have to
prove to yourself
that you get freedom you know once you
you know how many times you played a
game of say pool against someone and you
get nervous because you think that
they're better than you
well you're going to lose that game yeah
but once you
give over to there is no competition in
life the only person i can compete with
is myself and be the best neil mcdonough
that i can be
then competition goes out the window and
then you can really zone in on being the
best you actually can be
you can't be if you are taking other
people into consideration for
competition and that's a hard lesson to
learn you know going to those audition
rooms
you know you'd see you know when you're
a fresh actor you both see all these
other you know name faces in the room
like oh my gosh
what am i even doing here
you've already lost
you know so
it's once you realize how unique and
awesome you are that god creating only
one me or one you
then
then you don't care so much and then
when it doesn't go your way you don't
take it so brutally at times you know
and when it does go your way you don't
get so over excited because like yeah
well like that's where it should have
been
you know so you look at you know roger
federer playing tennis
you know when he wins it's
it was like day at the office when he
loses okay i lost that one i'll i'll try
i gotta figure out how to do better next
time
you know those kind of athletes are the
ones i always love watching because it's
not overly emotional
uh they just get their job done uh and
go home and kiss their wife and that's
kind of how i've run my career um at
least for the last 21 years so you never
to this you've gotten over that whole
thing of doubting or oh my god this
guy's better this you're not you've been
done with that for years you go in and
you do your job and you know what you're
gonna do and there's no fear there's no
sort of uh
worrying about can i can i do this when
you get a role or
no no it's i've never
i've never been that guy i've always i'm
always really look i know god gave me
this great talent i'm not going to waste
it
you know so when it comes to
entertaining i'm i know how to entertain
i know how to you know be in front of a
camera i know how to get the most out of
other actors how to make a scene better
you know you know it's
something you know i i've always been
really good at it and
you know it's like
when you play with better players your
game gets lifted you know my hearing
coach in high school says when you play
with crap you play like crap
you can use the crap board use a
different one
you know and that's always kind of stuck
in my brain that when you when you play
with better players your game goes up
and so i love
playing with great players um right and
it's it's been you know i've been
blessed to be able to work with you know
some of the know greatest actors and
directors in hollywood and it's it's you
know basically says you know you got to
write a book saying just famous enough
because you can you know you can
travel everywhere everyone knows your
face you know everyone says hi but but
you don't have a camera stuck up your
backside everywhere you go yeah because
i love acting i'm great at what i do but
you know it's
you know my life is so much more
important to me than than just acting
and and
um
and bringing up these five kids that's
that's paramount for a van that's
beautiful you know ryan was ryan my uh
engineer editor was just talking before
this he's like he was in angels in
america
angels in the outfield in the outfield
angels in the outfield i mean that's a
totally different thing angel's yeah
because angel's in the outfield but like
i was and he was like and there's so
many names in that movie here here's
here's angel's the outfield for you so
my mommy just passed away and i was just
devastated back in 1993.
i was back home for a couple months i
was like i want to keep doing this i
just kind of moved to hollywood i did a
few mini-series and stuff and things
were starting to come
and after that i was just devastated and
then i came out to hollywood because
they're auditioning for this movie
angels the outfield and it's funny
uh eisenhower's favorite film of all
time was the original angels in the
outfield this little tidbit there
nice nice um so you know what i
auditioned for it in in the script it
says whit bass throws pitch
and i told the director you know i play
college baseball you know i've got some
ideas i want to make this guy really
quirky and and different and such and
he's like great perfect you get the part
and because i came with such confidence
so
um
during uh they had like a baseball boot
camp and you know it's carny lansford
all these sex pro guys you know after a
couple days of boot camp like no you can
just you don't have to be here you can
just you know take the week off and do
whatever you want but we got to work
these guys you know for baseball because
not a very good baseball player great
so i went back to my hotel room and
every day i would look in the mirror and
try to figure out the goofiest things
for this character
and so i came up with the idea of um and
i went to the director and there's tens
of thousands of fans in the stadium
in oakland i said it's my first shot
first shot of the moon first shot of a
movie
any movie uh and i said look if give me
a favor can you follow me with the
camera i'm gonna come in from you know
from first base i'm gonna do something
going into the mound he looks at me like
i have nine heads he's like what
can just trust me just one day it's only
is one thing but i've got this great
idea i've been working out of my hotel
room for the last week
and bill dear bless his soul said
okay boys follow me on the counter and i
work this this thing sliding in my in my
hotel room so
i i would run in from first base slide
into the pitcher's mound circle the
mount a few times grab the rosin bag do
this crazy stuff and throw the first
pitch and the place went bonkers just
lost it bill's like you can do anything
you want you know after that since then
i've worked in a few movies with bill
but it's that stupid
what
that i've had since i was a kid that my
mom instilled in me there's no one like
you neil there's no one like you you
know as a kid i had dyslexia i had a
lisp all these impediments against me
you know you know and and and to
to have this kind of confidence that my
mom instilled in me you know was
you know
amazing and then you know when i met
rivein 2000 you know i finally had
someone you know a woman in my my corner
again and still infusing that confidence
in me and it's just kept going but i've
been blessed that i've had two women
mentors in my life that have always kind
of
pressed me to be the best that i could
be and because of that i have is dumb
confidence and and i can get up in front
of thousands of people and speak and
you know and do these things because you
know that that's the messages that i
have and who i am and what i stand for
is is you know it's i guess it's kind of
unique and it's just
it's me and have you ever had a director
call you like spielberg or anybody like
that just
you just nodded your head spielberg
called you
yeah okay well one of the best calls
steven ever made to me
was uh we had just done
a pilot called uh boomtown you know i
just did vanderbrothers and i just did a
minority report
[Music]
and
it was supposed to be jimmy smits was
supposed to play this hispanic sworthy
lover type guy on on boomtown and he
dropped out in the 11th hour and stephen
said what about neil mcdonough and
uh they called me and i auditioned for
it i got the part and pilot went great
was an awesome show
uh and we're in montreal
uh doing timeline uh and i still didn't
didn't have a whole lot of money at the
time and revay and i went to this really
high-end jewelry store looking at
you know
wedding rings and she saw one and she
said this is the one i really wanted i
was like oh my gosh that's so expensive
oh my gosh i'll never be able to afford
this what am i going to do what am i
going to do
hi stephen
hey neil what are you doing right now
i'm in the jewelry shop looking for a
ring for her bed because buy her one the
size of texas because boom town just got
picked up for a full season
okay thank you buddy
what he called you
and that was it
you know and
and you know i went to the to the guy i
said oh my can you hold this ring for me
for like a month or two here's a little
money but i just want to make sure that
this money's coming in but this is the
rate she wants he's like no problem i'll
save it for you and he did and
uh you know if it weren't for steven
spielberg my gosh i would certainly not
be here talking to you right now because
you know you're giving a guy you know i
basically stopped acting in the late 90s
99 i said you know i did pretty well had
a good career
it wasn't really really taking off it
was you know 10 years now of doing it
you know had fun i'll just go home and
do you know local theater in boston or
whatever but i'll go home and run the
motel with my my dad and you know we'll
do that
and i got a call um a friend of mine
said steven spielberg's looking for you
for this show called band of brothers
really because yeah they went to
audition like when
tuesday
and i got a one-way ticket because i was
not
good not good i was going to get this
part
uh one-way ticket for 693 dollars that's
all the money i had and i slept i went
to audition for it uh and when i wanted
to audition um there's like 15 people in
the room but at this point i
i had no fear whatsoever because if it
didn't work i'm going back to cape cod
it's good
uh and i'm like who do i read with and
all of a sudden this hand reaches up and
it's tom hanks
what the heck is going on here yeah uh
and after about 10 seconds he defused
any tension and did the audition and
after the audition he says you know that
you crushed that dungeon like yeah i do
because all right once you come back
tomorrow and once you read from buck
compton great came back to the next day
on record by compton and slept on my
buddy's
uh
closet floor uh for three months waiting
for the final callback and got the final
call back and then i finally got the
part and you know remember the first
call was to my dad that you know i got
banner brothers and then you know the
first night i got to london i met rave
and because of that i mean we did
you know when we were in another great
steven stories where we at the banner
brothers at the golden globes we just
won the golden globe for best mini
series
and we tried to get into trader vic's
it was me and raven and a bunch of the
bender brothers guys and you know the
security guys are like uh
no there's a certain roped off area that
was just all the huge celebrities and
they weren't having none of us uh and
stephen saw rebay and i and you walked
across and he grabbed me and you had to
lift the rope just come is this come on
in
it was a great night because how would
you like to play tom cruise's best foul
minority reporter
and i squeezed rave's hard her hand like
i literally thought i broke every and
i'm trying to be like steve mcqueen cool
yes that sounds great i'd
meanwhile inside i'm just like
you know fireworks and getting bonkers
inside i would be i would be an idiot me
i'd be like what are you kidding hell
yeah i would
and it was you know so he's you know
from that and you know
you know other you know flags for our
fathers and uh public morals and you
know the missing one he loves you wow to
have steven spielberg in your corner
you're doing all right
and he's he was he's been certainly a
mentor to me and
you know and phenomenal to my career and
i i can never ever say thank you enough
to steven spielberg for giving the
opportunity because
who knows if i ever would have met
revenge right with but you know
the life that i've had ever since i met
steven compared before i met steven uh
it's the gift that keeps giving every
day
all right this is called this is it this
is called uh rapid fire with uh i'm
sorry this is called [ __ ] talking with
neil mcdonough this is uh rapid fire so
you just answer fast these are from my
patrons if you want to join patreon
please do patreon.com inside of you it's
a fun family here we go leanne p
you have been in many tv series over the
years and played many roles are there
any roles or genres that you refuse to
portray or act in
no
badly written ones
lauren w you're such a nice guy in real
life what is the most fun bad guy you
have ever played
walking tall is a blast because i got to
do it opposite dwayne and he's such a
great one of my favorite scenes of all
time was was uh the last scene where he
takes the the big wood log and smashes
my legs against the trees
and dwayne was having a hard time coming
up with that
instead of just that look on his face
the director's like no no be emotional
emotional you got to get emotional and
i'm saying the camera's on him my face
is right here the camera's right here
and here's to waiting right in front of
me
emotionally i can't get out emotionally
you couldn't get my hold on one second i
go over to the craft service table
and i get before and this is where the
stupid confidence comes back in i get
about four or five packets of ketchup
and i squeeze them into my mouth and the
director sees what i'm doing
and
he yells action and he smashes my legs
as soon as he smashes my legs i
spit blood all over his face which is
ketchup
to look on dwayne's face i thought he
was literally going to kill me and he
swung so hard with this rubber mallet
that you know and afterwards i fell to
the floor laughing in hysterics because
you know i it worked i got him but it
was you know to play to be you know into
that kind of character and play it and
really tap into it and also to help out
another actor to to be the best that he
can possibly be
it was what was was you know you know
when you look at all the villains that i
played and i played a lot of them
it's hard to beat that one you know
yellowstone was great because i got to
go opposite kevin which is you know
kevin costa's
pound for pound i consider probably the
greatest you know screen actor of all
time he understands the camera better
than anybody
um but uh working with delaney was wow
michelle k if you could have a mulligan
for something what would it be
a mulligan for something yeah i'm kind
of trying to figure out i know what a
mulligan is like in golf you get an
extra swing
right
yeah you know it's funny my daughter
clover a couple weeks ago asked me dad
if you could go back and
be 45 instead of 55 would you do it i
said no
i said if if that were the case i would
have missed all the steps between 45 and
55 and watching all you kids grow and
and all that stuff so you know i
wouldn't change i'm not really a
mulligan guy
you you know what what what god's given
me is so
you know
knee bucklingly incredible and and
awesome and inspiring and
you know so
you learn from your mistakes and if you
don't learn from your mistakes you're
not really being a great human being we
all make mistakes we all do dumb stuff
but like i said before it's it's the
ones who
who get up and dust themselves off and
realize you know what they did and try
to be better and and so mulligans to
make our hearts so interesting
um
so no all right no mulligans man uh last
one little lisa do you have any funny
behind-the-scenes stories from arrow or
legends of tomorrow
um
well go
insane if i had to do a mulligan uh
the only the only thing that i miss in
my life
is pairing the two greatest women that
i've ever had in my life in the same
room
you know my mom never met rebay and
that's
i appreciate you
i mean i could see how important that is
to you i mean that that came to you i
mean you don't need to say anything you
don't need to say anything after that
i'm not sure if it's a mulligan but
you know it'll happen one day later on
when when we're all said and done but
you know we've got me going man come on
you're getting me going now neil
see you're doing what you did to the
rock to me
ketchup please you're rocking me you're
rocking me right now gosh
uh by the way did you do any impressions
no you know it's people say tell me a
joke i can't remember a joke to save my
life you know it's
you know
impressions you know i'm not much of the
impression guy you know i'm always on
ted baxter you know for the mary tyler
moore show
you know that that's a good day tonight
those kinds of guys i loved growing up
yeah but
impressions you know i guess the
impressions kind of like
you know my priest growing up you know
you know
you know father duffy was just you know
i remember at my mom's dream role
i was talking to my brother about
earlier today father duffy was the you
know
uh this priest who'd been on there way
too long and uh was a friend of the
family but he had alzheimer's
and at my mother's funeral he shot
father duffy you know from boston
started talking about karen mcdougall
how how close she is catherine mcdonough
and his sidekick father ozone would be
peppered yeah catherine would uh you
know in the himalayas the ouija boards
and literally you go off in these
tangents so you know if i'm doing an
impression it's about it's generally
people characters from me growing up as
a kid in boston that
these characters are just so
you know embedded you know in in my
skull
uh that you know i use those characters
uh for characters that i play and
i i love being able to tap into the
crazy bizarre world of growing up in
boston
in cape cod
and and finding these real life you know
from from very wealthy businessmen to
carpenters who have dream problems or
businessmen are driving problems
um you know that's that's those are my
impressions well man this is this is i
hope you had fun this has been really
fun for me and i i i hate that this is
the way we have to catch up but hey
i love that i got to know so much more
about you and the family and and your
life and i really appreciate you taking
the time and i can't wait to to see you
guys again i really can't
so we got to make that happen
it was awesome it's been too long last
time i saw you was you know in a hockey
room
in a locker room was i dressed was i
dressed now
uh
kind dressed somewhat dressed yeah yeah
um keep it clean
you ordered i was
you know but uh yeah you know i i miss
seeing you now that we're moving back to
we're really excited about that i'm
excited to get home and um you know my
brother-in-law ryan who's you know one
of my best friends you know to hang out
with ryan and jen and you know all my
other friends back in los angeles and uh
to be back there is is i i can't wait to
get back everywhere i want to hang out
with you when you come back you got to
invite me over i got to meet the kids
and all that oh you will you will for
sure for sure i love that i would love
that i'll keep it clean don't worry i
know what i'm doing here they've heard
it they have um this has been a joy i
love you give my love to rave and uh
thanks for doing this thanks brother all
right man bless you guys god bless you
[Music]
thanks for listening to the podcast
today uh i really appreciate it if you
like the podcast if you want to
subscribe that would be grand spread the
word go on our uh uh twitter what's the
uh the the handles if they want to
follow us they are at inside of you pod
on twitter at insideablepodcast on
instagram and facebook
yes that would be amazing and subscribe
go to youtube you can watch these uh
spread the word also just another shout
out to my patrons who i love you uh if
you want to join and give a little
to the podcast a little indigestion here
if you want to give a little more to the
podcast you can go to patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n patreon.com inside of you
and i'll write you a message after you
join and uh there's lots of perks and
it's a bunch of great stuff it's become
a big family a lot of people become very
close friends through the patreon i
never knew what it was and now i just
think it's think the world of it because
so many people have gotten so close have
you heard that yeah
who doesn't want a new friend yeah i
mean you really do meet people who have
the same interests and i can name many
people uh leanne's become friends with
janine and uh
you know um betsy's become good friends
with i mean it's just like you know they
i see it and it makes me smile so join
patreon go to patreon.com inside of you
also go to the inside of you online
store if you want any merch
great merch um lex luthor stuff and the
sunspin.com you can get uh band stuff
like this cool shirt i'm wearing and you
can book a zoom with me
and uh and you can check when we're
playing because we play every month
so ryan did you have a uh did you have a
good week i had to go i had a good week
i didn't ask you on the intro no because
we gotta save for the outros now because
we got to get to it well we we can get
to it but it's nice to just at least you
know see check in yeah week was fine
you're you're doing well you got a
haircut i i got a haircut and you got a
haircut we had a week of haircuts we did
we lost we i think we look a little
younger i don't know if i look younger
with a haircut i think i look older with
a haircut no i think you look younger
with a haircut are you sure yeah is it
the glasses that make me older
let's get inside of the patrons
i'm going to give the shout outs these
are to the top tier patrons who give a
lot to the podcast and i don't forget
them i think about them fondly and they
go above and beyond
let's go nancy d leah s trisha f sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e brian h mama
lauren nico p jerry w robert l jason w
apothean
kristen k amelia oh alison l raj c
joshua d emily s cjp
samantha m jennifer n stacy l jen s
jamal f janelle b kimberly e mike e
eldon supremo that's dan 99 more ramirez
santiago m sarah f chad w leanne p
janine are rey a maya p matty s shannon
d matt w belinda
and don't know how you got that one
james r chris h dave h spider-man chase
sheila g
brad d ray h tab of the t tom and
liliana a michelle k michael s talia m
betsy d
claire baby
laura l chad l rochelle nathan e marion
meg k janelle p travel dan n o
ah jennifer not jeff
lorraine g carrie h veronica k big
stevie w kendall t carol d
angel m
rhiannon c
i don't think that's it i think it's not
a few more there's a few more how do you
know that because i know
i know what the last few look like all
right you're right it's not random c
cory k super sam emily c coleman g
dev nexon michelle a liz l jeremy c andy
t cody r sebastian k gavinator
and h dave c
elliott m john b brandy d yvore camille
s bono orbano bono we do this every time
the c the c like the and then the letter
c
joey mpts
and willie f
hey thanks for uh the new listeners the
new members of patreon
and uh i really appreciate it my week
was pretty uh
it was pretty good i'm always you know
i'm working on myself and uh working on
the stress levels and the anxiety and
trying to
you know we can control our thoughts in
a lot of ways it's not really that you
can control your thoughts but you could
sort of
guide your thoughts and you can like
stop yourself when you're going down
this dark path and say stop this is a
thought this isn't real this hasn't
happened i do that sometimes i stop
myself shut the [ __ ] up
this isn't real what are you doing to
yourself
anyway i'll leave you with that
uh
from the hollywood hills the hollywood
hills of california that's michael rose
bobby and i brian is over here hello
we wait to the camera we do it all the
time and uh thank you for allowing to be
inside of each and every one of you
thanks for listening the podcast thanks
for supporting the podcast supporting me
supporting ryan
bryce
um
all of us
and uh
yeah
thank you thank you so much
[Music]